mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
a circle contains four identical squares
as shown
each square has a side length equal to
two
what is the radius of the circle
i adapted this problem from the twitter
account see shearer41
pause if you'd like to give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
in the video solve for the radius harder
than it looks
the challenge was to solve for the
radius of this circle in terms of the
lengths a b and c
we derived the following formula
in this video i'm going to prove this
formula once again and then we will use
this formula to solve the original
problem
let's get started
draw a horizontal length equal to b
then draw a vertical length that
connects to the circle
by symmetry this length must be equal to
c
we then connect these two line segments
and this length will be equal to a
we then extend the line segment with a
length of b to the other side of the
circle and label this length as d
by power of a point or the intersecting
coordinates theorem we must have b
multiplied by d
is equal to the product of c and a plus
c we divide both sides by b to get the
following formula for d
we then draw the following chord of the
circle
notice this chord is opposite an
inscribed right angle so it must be a
diameter of the circle with a length
equal to 2r
then in this right triangle we can use
the gogu theorem
we have a squared plus the quantity b
plus d squared must be equal to 2r the
quantity squared
now let's do some algebra
we'll substitute in for d
then we'll expand out and continue to
expand out
we are now going to carefully factor the
numerator
we'll do this as follows
the first four terms can be factored as
follows
we factor out a b squared and we get the
following formula
the next four terms we can factor out a
common factor of c squared we get the
following formula
we substitute those in
now we're going to divide both sides by
four
then we're going to take the positive
square root because we want a positive
radius
we thus get the formula for the radius
so how does this help us we've solved
this problem but we now want to solve
for the radius of this circle
well let's convert our current problem
into the one we've already solved
we'll draw this vertical length then a
horizontal length and then another
vertical length
notice that this vertical length is
equal to two
this horizontal length will be the
length of four squares so it's equal to
eight and finally this vertical length
will be one side of the square and equal
to two
so if a is equal to two b is equal to
eight and c is equal to two
to show you why let's just rotate this
diagram
and we have a is equal to 2 b is equal
to 8 and c is equal to 2.
we can then substitute into the formula
and then we simplify it and we
immediately get that the radius is equal
to the square root of 85 all over 2
which is approximately 4.61 and that's
our answer
i love that this problem reduces to 1
we've already solved
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
you